à peine sortis d'une crise sanitaire
sans précédent de nouveaux tourments
pour est agité le gouvernement même si
le niveau de mobilisation en france n'a
pas atteint celui des etats-unis les
images de la manifestation de ce mardi à
paris sont impressionnantes
au moins vingt mille personnes selon la
préfecture de police
réunis pour réclamer justice et vérité
dans la sphère adama traoré
rassemblement qui fait écho à la
situation outre atlantique et qui a
provoqué beaucoup de réactions
et si du côté l'elysée c'est silence
radio pour le moment selon cet article
du parisien
l' affaire est prise très au sérieux aux
étages les plus élevés du pouvoir on
craint cependant que le rassemblement
mardi devant le tribunal judiciaire de
paris ouvre la porte à d'autres
manifestations dans les jours qui
viennent
cela fait plusieurs jours qu'on sent le
truc venir il y a potentiellement un
effet de mimétisme avec les états unis
même si la situation n'est pas du tout
la même là bas l'exécutif marche sur des
oeufs et veut éviter de nouvelles
manifestations
un participant au conseil des ministres
sous couvert d'anonymat
déclare ainsi au parisien après les
gilets jaunes les retraites et le co
vide
la majorité n'a pas les moyens
d'affronter une nouvelle crise qui pour
le coup condamnerait définitivement ce
quinquennat une situation délicate qui
provoque quelques oscillations dans la
communication gouvernementale
après le tweet très ferme de christophe
castaner le lendemain de la
manifestation pour adama la porte parole
du gouvernement se montre prudente lors
du point presse à la suite du conseil
des ministres dans la manifestation qui
a eu lieu hier c'est une manifestation
qui bien qu'interdite s'est déroulé
pendant la majeure partie du temps dans
le calme dans la sérénité il y a eu en
fin de manifestation moment de sa
dispersion des événements qui évidemment
sont condamnables et qui sont tout à
fait regrettable une forme de en même
temps appliqué à ce dossier des
violences policières
un numéro d'équilibriste qui peut
s'avérer compliqué surtout que le
président de la république semble avoir
évolué sur cette question alors candidat
emmanuel macron expliqué je cite quand
il y à des violences policières sur le
terrain on doit donner tout
éclaircissement à ces violences deux ans
plus tard le même
emmanuel macron devenu président de la
république affirme
ne parlez pas de répression de violences
policières ces mots sont inacceptables
dans un état de droit
un revirement certainement accentué par
la crise des gilet jaune ou les vidéos
d'usagé disproportionné de la force ont
placé la question des violences
policières dans l'espace médiatique et
politique
d'ailleurs quelques gilet jaune était
présent à la manifestation de mardi et
certains appellent à une convergence
pour les prochains rassemblements
rassemblements qui ont été interdits par
les autorités en raison du contexte
sanitaire les à l'heure où des
manifestations se déroulent aux quatre
coins de la planète
ces interdictions risquent peut-être
d'aggraver la défiance contre le
gouvernement